en el lecho del río huaura una chalupa
pasa volando en su interior ésta lo
instala acaba de revisar los avances de
la obra más reciente de su empresa
especializada en energías innovadoras
aquí vamos de cerca a la ciudad de duala
para la instalación de una central solar
la solar una energía limpia que lo
instala pretende desarrollar masivamente
en pueblos habitados como este poner las
placas sobre pilotes de lo contrario las
inundaciones estarán en ocho años el
conquistó el sector de las energías
renovables y su facturación se alcanzó
los 15 millones de euros un éxito
rotundo para esta mujer que tuvo que
hacerse un lugar en una industria
camerunesa ampliamente dominada por los
hombres la primera dificultad son los
prejuicios siempre se cree que la mujer
es incapaz de alcanzar sus objetivos nos
conceden incluso contratos tan sólo para
ver si podemos lograrlo pero al final
todo el mundo queda contento se lo
garantizo tengo socios que están muy
contentos con lo que hago posible
trascender todas estas dificultades ya
sean humanas financieras o sociales y
social el emprendimiento en femenino una
lucha conducida por lo instala en la
palpitante capital económica anima
talleres de coaching como éste varias
veces al mes somos buenas dirigentes
porque las empresas manejadas por
mujeres son las mejores en áfrica
subshariana una empresa de cada tres le
pertenece a una mujer
esto es coaching son para hacerlo
entender a la joven africana que puede
emprender para hacerles entender la
necesidad de no depender de nadie
volverse independiente financieramente
en esta sociedad patriarcal es la
principal motivación de lilian quien
está inscrita en estas sesiones de
mentoring femenino
aprendí mucho durante esta presentación
durante este coaching porque una mujer
que quiere emprender de verdad que
quiere volverse una mujer fuerte como se
dice debe apoyarse en el desarrollo
personal sostenible tras una jornada
agotadora
louis regresa con su familia
cotidianamente hace malabares entre sus
dos condiciones la de mujer de negocios
y la de madre de familia en camerún con
frecuencia la mujer sigue a cargo de la
educación de los hijos estos niños son
nuestra vida los niños es lo que dios
nos dio lo más preciado corremos a la
izquierda y a la derecha pero después
cuando nos encontramos es muy agradable
a danielle su esposo también es
empresario y entiende las dificultades
de su mujer para manejar los dos roles
de la agenda de cualquier dirigente
empresaria
es exigente es dirigente de empresa
familiar
entonces es más responsable de ella
misma el destino de su empresa del
destino de su familia
ella conduce mucho más la familia que yo
efe
sólo 5000 mujeres dirigen una de las
200.000 empresas censadas en el país y
ciertas dirigentes se ilustran en
sectores más bien inesperados
en esta periferia de duala en medio de
estos tubos industriales se encuentra
drincic o mejor conocida como la reina
de la metalurgia el diámetro es de
cuánto 855 terminado ok
esta ex modelo y cantante dirige desde
hace 17 años esta empresa que factura
cerca de un millón de euros al año hoy
está supervisando el trabajo de un
centenar de empleados todos hombres pero
aspira a que las mujeres con quiste en
el tejido industrial camerunés
si me respetan en el oficio primero los
hombres nuevo el oficio en general es
porque primero que todo soy una mujer de
terreno
una reputación adquirida con el paso de
los años el chaqué para los
colaboradores de audrey chico contar con
una mujer dirigente no era algo evidente
siete papás y no era fácil trabajar con
nuestro director general
bien de vez en cuando nos daba órdenes
el paso del tiempo entendimos que sólo
el trabajo cuenta en el servicio ellas
ven libros con un rigor bien aplicado
por su director técnico quien también en
su esposo una situación muy rara en el
país
cuando se trata de decisiones
importantes para el futuro de la
sociedad se habla se negocia entre
nosotros así es como se discute entre un
responsable de alto y su superior esposa
colette minka ve con buenos ojos la
llegada de jóvenes mujeres luchadoras al
mundo de la empresa esta pionera posee y
dirige la primera sociedad de temporales
que ubica a cerca de cinco mil
asalariados al año para sus clientes en
toda la subregión de áfrica central o la
señora dama pero cuando lanzó su empresa
en los años 90 colette minga tuvo que
superar numerosas dificultades los
bancos rechazaban otorgarle un crédito
última al principio contábamos solamente
con dos clientes fui al banco para
obtener un descubierto de 1.500.000 ni
le cuento lo que sufrí para obtener ese
desde el año 2000 hasta ahora
la actividad no ha hecho sino crecer hoy
en día este representante de las
emprendedoras camerunesas obtiene más
fácilmente el apoyo de los bancos pero
sigue siendo una excepción porque el
acceso a crédito sigue siendo difícil
para las mujeres en áfrica sub-sahariana
menos del 40 por ciento de ellas poseen
una cuenta bancaria pero nada frena a
colette acaba de lanzar una nueva
empresa para administrar la flota de
automóviles de alta gama de grandes
empresas y espera inspirar a más mujeres
camerunesas a forjar su destino